[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, my name is Daniel
Olshansky.
I'm an intern on the
Android team.
And today, I'll be talking
about image pixelization.
I'll discuss a couple different
variations of how
you can achieve an image
pixelization effect, using
some built-in operations
and using some custom
operations as well.
Furthermore, I'll discuss the
use of AsyncTask, which is an
object you can use to offload
work off of the UI thread onto
a background thread.
And then you can keep
your UI complete and
responsive while doing so.
One of the tricks that you'll
see, while you're doing the
image pixelization effect, is
the fact that when we want to
use some built-in operations,
what you can actually do is
downscale a bitmap and
upscale it back up.
And you'll see the use of a flag
called filter, which we
can use to vary between bilinear
filtering and point
sampling when we're actually
doing the pixelization effect.
So let's jump straight
to demo right here.
And we just have an image of
a couple of jellyfish.
And as we move the SeekBar bar
from left to right, you can
see that the image is getting
pixelized more or less.
But you can also tell that as
my finger's moving, the
SeekBar is behind where
my actual finger is.
So there's a significant
lag here.
If we use AsyncTask, you
can see that the image
pixelization is exactly the
same as it was before.
It takes the same
amount of time.
But the UI remains completely
responsive.
And the SeekBar never
lags behind.
If you look here, we can also
use the built-in pixelization
effect, which is significantly
faster.
And even though it's still on
the UI thread and not on
background thread, you can tell
that it's still keeping
up to my finger, exactly
where it needs to be.
So then jumping straight into
the code and going down, there
is some boilerplate code, which
you can look over later.
And a simple SeekBar listener to
make sure that every single
time that the value changes, we
pixelate the image to get a
new pixelized image
on the screen.
Scrolling down further more,
we get to where the actual
custom pixelization begins.
So for custom pixelization,
all we're going to do is
implement this algorithm where
you're going to loop through
all the pixels in the image.
You're going to average the
values of the red, green, and
blue channels within every
single pixel to some value.
And then you're going to set
that same pixel value to all
the pixels within that region.
The key thing to note here is
the fact that when you're
retrieving, we're setting
pixel values.
You never want to use SetPixel
or GetPixel if you know that
you're going to use
more than those.
There's a few methods available
in the bitmap class,
such as GetPixels or SetPixels,
where you can
immediately set an array
of pixels or
get an array of pixels.
And they'll be significantly
faster.
So here we're getting
the pixels.
We're averaging everything
out.
And at the end, we set the
pixels in that bitmap.
We then return to
BitmapDrawable.
And then this BitmapDrawable is
applied to the ImageView,
which you see on the
screen afterwards.
Now scrolling down farther
more, we move into the
built-in pixelization effect.
And like I said before, all this
does here is we do a few
simple calculations to determine
what the downscaled
width and height should be
in order to achieve that
pixelization effect.
But the important thing is
here, when we create a
downscaled bitmap, we have to
set the filter value to false.
So what this does is
use point sampling
instead of bilinear filtering.
So it doesn't actually average
out the values of the pixel
values around it.
But it achieves this very
blocky, pixely effect that
we're looking for.
Going down here--
so after we downscale it, we
know that we need to upscale
it back up.
So before JellyBean MR1, the
way we do this is simply
create a scaled bitmap and
upscale it back to the
original width and height with
that filter value to false.
However, after JellyBean MR1,
what you can actually do is
create a BitmapDrawable with
that image and set the filter
bitmap to false.
The thing is that before JB MR1,
we always had the filter
bitmap set to true for some
optimization purposes.
But what this lets you do here
is not actually upscale the
bitmap, simply set the filter.
And then, given that the image
use scale type is fit xy, when
we apply this BitmapDrawable
to the ImageView what will
happen is that it will upscale
it in a much more efficient
manner to fit the
whole screen.
So here in invoke
pixelization--
this is the method that gets
invoked every single time the
SeekBar is moved.
And there's two different
things that you can do.
If the check box is checked,
use AsyncTask.
What we're going to do is
initialize this pixelized
image AsyncTask object and
call execute with the
appropriate parameters, which
is the value of the SeekBar
and the bitmap that
we're pixelizing.
Moving into pixelize image
AsyncTask, we can see that
there's two key methods
that you want to note.
There's doInBackground and
there's OnPostExecute.
So what happens-- when you
call execute with the
appropriate parameters,
doInBackground is called on
the background thread.
It does the operations you
can see performed here.
And when this operation
completes on the background
thread, it calls OnPostExecute
back on the UI thread, where
we simply set the drawable
to what we want.
On the other hand, if the check
box was not checked,
then we simply set the
image drawable.
And this is done directly in the
UI thread, which is why we
were seeing the laggy experience
while scrolling the
SeekBar as before.
So that's pretty much it.
And that's how you can do image
pixelization and move
things onto a background thread
when you need to.
Thanks.